hi everyone mad Luigi here and don't
worry I can still make Souls content now
first off I want to say that we will
always have the soul game we currently
do so in a way there is no what comes
after Dark Souls because the games never
end we can always go back and play them
but from a more pragmatic view our fire
and passion for these games will and/or
have simmered down because we've already
gone through them so many times and now
we're looking into the future
wondering what comes next well anything
filled the Dark Souls needs before I get
too into the video I do want to say I
had no idea that there was a plethora of
souls like games coming out in the near
future so a big thank you to fellow
youtuber paragon DS and his most recent
video for enlightening me on that you
guys like my Dark Souls content you most
assuredly would like his to go check
them out but his most recent video is
what gave this video like let me know
that they're going to get a ton of
copycats of souls that we get to check
out and make fun of now but seriously
there are going to be quite a few games
that are going to try to recapture the
magic of the souls Bourne franchise made
the surge is a new game coming out in
like a week or two that looks like
industrial souls I just saw the trailer
for code vein Bandai Namco's new game
and fully solely Batman that game wants
to be animate our souls side note I did
maybe take that anime Dark Souls thing
for me YouTube comment but it's like the
perfect description so I'm keeping it I
was really caught off guard by how
blatant the plot story described by that
trailer was just a description of
Halloween in Dark Souls and there are
sure to be others that crop up here and
there and I really think these are
something that I'm going to be wanting
to cover on my channel I know I didn't
cover neo which was the most recent most
popular souls like game so I don't have
too good of a track record on this but
to be fair that came out when I was on
one of my YouTube hiatuses when I wasn't
really making much content hopefully
that's not going to happen yet I'm sure
that all of you who have enjoyed my
souls videos would like to see something
from me on the games there are a lot of
similarities and you'll probably want to
know how well the games actually end up
before purchasing them since they are
looking like full price games I'm pretty
sure the surge of sixty bucks and I
would be very very surprised if Bandai
Namco did not give their own gain a $60
price tag being frank I don't think that
nav games will actually capture the
souls experience but I don't think I
want them to to me no game look
for the experience of a Bethesda RPG
other than a pathetic RPG Skyrim is only
going to feel like skyress The Witcher 3
is an experience I'll only have in The
Witcher 3 good game standalone how they
present their material so I want these
new games even though they seem to be
trying to use the souls formula to
become something different and something
I enjoy for themselves I know they're
not going to do as well at being souls
as Souls did because souls souls so why
would I think anything that isn't soul
is going to be a better soul from
software are the best people at making
souls so I don't want these other people
to try and make souls if they want to
use the formula souls hat and make
something new and unique that would be
great if the amazing of Dark Souls could
start its own mini genre of action RPGs
but in that genre every game would be
different and unique look at the
first-person shooter genre that is a
huge wide scope of radically different
games that played differently feel
differently and people like the
different games for their own benefits
looking at call of duty and halo those
games play drastically different or at
least they used to they're both FPS but
they have their own unique benefits that
make people prefer one or the other or
just appreciate both for different
reasons if all the new games are just
carbon copies of souls and we wouldn't
get much of a mini genre it would just
be the same game over and over the game
as closest coming out is the surge
developing dec 13 the people behind
Lords of the Fallen another souls like
game that I didn't cover I didn't
actually play it but I know reviews
weren't the greatest they released NYX
we can help this studio has learned from
the first go-around and gotten better
the setting for the surge an industrial
one is a nice change from medieval you
know I know Lords of the Fallen was
close to the Dark Souls on that medieval
setting so industrial kind of like the
movie Elysium setting is a little bit
better in terms of going away from souls
while still using the same core concepts
I will also be saying the gameplay does
look pretty well developed and fun on
the surge it looks like it uses Souls
elements but adds in some of its own
like jump and duck dodging the game
drops may 16th which is coming up pretty
quick I'll be doing first impressions
reviews and overall looks of the game so
if you want to wait to see if it's good
before you buy it I got you covered and
I do plan to do
similar kind of things to the other
Souls like games that come out in the
future such as code vain and a couple
other ones I haven't mentioned so the
future of souls fans not too bleak we
definitely got some games to give and
look at for ones that can potentially be
pretty good I just hope they don't try
to make another Souls game but try and
use that formula to make something new
different and good in its own right
anyways I hope you enjoyed the short
video let me know what you think about
these upcoming Souls like mention
anything you want to see me do within
I'll see you in my next moving picture
peace out